[Music]
we live in a world obsessed with body
image in the way that we look well
people think I'm this hideous monster
when I go out but what happens when the
way you think you look completely takes
over your life I used to sit in the
lounge and with the curtains drawn
because I was paranoid that someone
would look in children and teenagers up
and down the country are battling with
body dysmorphic disorder I was so ugly
that I just wasn't worth like to keep
going and so I just tried to yeah tender
quite a few times I think BDD is an
obsession with flaws in a person's
appearance that others would barely even
notice many cases where boy they've
actually done self surgery so kind of
injecting their nips with saline
solution trying it on themselves so it
is far worse one of the kind of the most
distressing conditions I've worked with
the Maudsley hospitals the only
specialist unit in the country to treat
those affected and we've been granted
exclusive access to tell their story
[Music]
eighteen year old Emily is obsessed with
makeup it's basically like covering my
floors and just like a camouflage for me
it's just my face in general I just hate
the way that I look
her body dysmorphia has got so bad that
she's missed virtually all of her
secondary education I've tried to hang
myself but they were all failed suicide
attempts and I fell disgusted with
myself and hideous I just didn't feel
pretty enough to even be in front of my
family right let's go but Emily is now
getting help therapy and medication
seems to be working and today she's
making the 200-mile journey from her
home and Stafford to the Maudsley
hospital in London with her dad John but
the start of the treatment she wouldn't
even leave the house for four years I
mean Emily was a school refuser
he couldn't plan we couldn't go on
holidays couldn't have any family
holidays even things like Christmas
family Christmases couldn't you could
organize those because we could get to a
point where we're about to leave the
house and she wouldn't be able to go
service will should be working in to
londonium today for children and
teenagers with BDD getting a diagnosis
can be tricky because it's an illness
that very little is known about I might
get something to the fillers in there
just to do that and then my chin is
really masculine it's really sharp and
square like a man's chin on the other
side of London Megan is still struggling
terribly Megan was a straight-a student
but as left school with very few
qualifications my mum would drive me and
we'd sit outside school and I just cry I
worry that you know they're all looking
at me and thinking and looking at
everything that's wrong with me leaving
the house is still a difficult task a
little bit nervous because at this time
there's gonna be some kids walking down
from there the two girls from the school
who are gonna come down here for her the
build up can take hours especially if
it's busy outside what's it like inside
very jittery yeah at the end of the road
you know I think I'd rather just go back
inside
give it a go please be honest I just
don't I know am i ugly my family and
Megan say social media doesn't help with
their illness
we've masked these youngsters identity
but they're seeking reassurances about
their appearance online pretty on the
likes of Instagram there are still
hundreds of thousands of harmful body
image posts and on Facebook certain
groups where members discuss taking
laxatives and 200 calorie a day diet
Facebook and Instagram insists they are
deeply concerned about the well-being of
people using their sites and don't
tolerate content that encourages
self-harm
back in January 17 year-old elias's bdd
got so bad that he was treated as an
inpatient in hospital for two months I
was like makeup isn't enough people can
still see my face I hate the way my face
looks I just can't bear people looking
at me and so I started wearing this like
here and then the hat but early
assistants made an incredible recovery
despite missing out on two years of
school I couldn't even go to the garden
mister times I couldn't leave my room so
which is pretty much confined to the
house really mom had to stay home she
had to stop working because she didn't
trust me to stay on my own if she was in
a room I wouldn't go into it and what
was that well because I felt I got so
bad that I felt okay no it's not just
other people it's my parents as well
they can't see me because I'm too ugly
for my parents to see me thank you
okay in southeast London Emily arrives
at the Maudsley clinic and today it's
all about taking her out of her comfort
zone therapist Amita wants to see how
far she's come so know this is hard but
really try and challenge yourself as
much as you can and the challenge today
for Emily is to remove her makeup and to
head outside
okhla him
okay so have a look around you and see
if people are still looking
she's conscious that people are staring
at her thinking that she's ugly I feel
like in this situation it's even more
challenging because obviously
we are sort of drawing attention to
ourselves
yeah so that's making me anxious she
gets to the end of the road before
panicking it's too busy she decides to
go back inside it just made me honestly
have like a panic attack
I felt really insecure a little bit
hopeless in a way and consultant Amita
has dealt with hundreds of patients like
Emily over the years we've had lots of
young people come in and they've come a
flood kind of the whole face so people
we've assessed where they've had kind of
towels on their heads because they just
can't even be bear to been seen by even
clinicians that are experts in BDD the
Mosley hospital is now going into
schools along with the mental health
charity rethink to raise awareness and
to carry out research so far their
analysis of around 600 11 to 16 year
olds has found that whilst 80% were
concerned with at least one part of
their body up to five percent could have
BDD many people with body dysmorphic
disorder wait years for a diagnosis in
when I was just talking to right now I
really wanted to look in the mirror I'm
sure people are thinking that's cause
she's vain
it's because I'm really worried that all
these people who are watching this are
gonna think you know she's really ugly
but in time people learn to manage their
symptoms it's the way that I'm coping
with it is differently so I'm thinking
you know so what who's gonna look at me
and are they with people looking at me
you know are they important in my life
and the likes of aleus give others hope
it is in your head and with enough
therapy like with the right therapy you
will get better and it will just you
will improve and you will go back to
normal life again there are high suicide
rates for those living with BDD some
refuse to get help for fear that they'll
be considered vain but with greater
awareness and research his hope more
youngsters will in future be diagnosed
earlier